From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Tell me, say your name.
Ready?
I'm ready.
No, say it.
Say your name.
Where were you born?
When?
I was born in Caryville, Florida.
My name is Robert Middle, initial L, fully, and Carter.
I think the name Robert is, is a name that's commonly, I don't think I have to spell that.
Lee is L-E-E and Carter is a common name that spells C-R-T-E-R.
So I think I have a common name that's not unusual.
I was not, I hoped, named after Robert E. Lee, but I may have been,
at the time, because I came from the South and during that period.
The Southern General's and stuff like that were considered heroic by black people, but I don't know.
I think that's the most important thing.
We're good to go.
Where should he look?
Look at you all?
Look at me?
Will that pick up on the camera?
Okay.
Did you pick it all up?
Yeah, no.
That was a test.
We're ready to go.
Okay.
Do you have something you want to hear at the lesson?
We're ready.
Okay.
Judge Carter, you're a child of the great migration.
Tell us about where and when you were born and how you came to come north.
I was born in Caryville, Florida.
When I was very young, after my mother birthed me, I was a part of my migration and family,
out of the deep south to the north and that (the) broke migration.
My family was born free.
I think maybe about 60 years after the Civil War.
We were a free, free blocks coming out of the south.
(the) Great Migration.
And what year was that?
What year were you born?
I was born in 1917.
In Caryville I said, or earlier, Caryville, Florida.
Where did your family move to?
Your father was already up north.
My father had, my mother was in Florida, birthed me.
I think that he was, or they were part of the migrant agricultural families.
But because of the war, I hear probably had some charisma, or was a man who was a man
who was just not a peon on, but he had some intelligence.
He had sent him north, and he was working in a factory.
After my mother birthed me, she joined him in the rest of the family in Newark.
What are your earliest memories about growing up in Newark?
Well, I was, my father died when I was a year old, and my mother had no special education.
She was not an ex-wife woman.
She had some schooling.
But she did not have enough schooling to get a job, other than as a washing clothes for white people.
And as she did to keep bread on the table for us.
And I lived with her by President Standards and poverty until I was 12.
When I was 12 years old, my older sister married.
She was a woman who sold and made clothes.
And she married this man who owned the bar in Linden, New Jersey.
And that was sort of like a big coming out of poverty.
She insisted that he remain at all the family of the together.
So she lived with him.
And the family all together and not enabled us to get better housing.
And every time we sort of moved, it was to improve our living conditions.
After I was 12 years old, I became, for the first time, with her marriage, I was able to have a bath room for myself.
So I ended up toilet and I was back.
Until that time, I had to use outhouses with other people.
I remember that I was such a state.
Fortunately, it was sort of hard marrying this man.
It was sort of like the period when I was known as White Fair Hotel, when this spoke about marriage is rich man.
And it was similar to that because it opened the door to me to mainstream parabatives.
I had never been an indoors toilet and stuff like that.
All of the, what I learned about the difference between the poor and the rich, for example, is poor people never or rarely learn what they need to know.
Because I live middle class people, can't live on the streets and stuff like that.
But when it comes time, but they need to know something, they know where to get it.
And second thing, the poor and the rich, is that the poor people, poor people, act out there, live on the streets.
Middle class people do the same thing but behind doors.
They do not, they have porches or stuff, and they do not have to live their life on the street.
So when I was a boy in the street, which was once the worst storms in the ghetto, it has been rehabilitated or what you call it.
Because now the city of Newark has redone boys with one of the worst storms in the ghetto.
But I was rejected, I did, what of that, you call that doing?
Well, education, you wrote in your memoir that your desire for education, early on, inspired you.
What, I mean, schooling and education, what opened you up to that in the way that you went ahead and you didn't see it so well?
I was not skillful with my hands.
I knew that somehow I was going to find a way into the mainstream and get an education and find my way there.
And what I recognized was the only way I could do that was a good education.
I was considered smart and I skipped at skipped school and stuff like that.
And that was an advantage to me. And also I read a lot on discipline reading, but at the same time it exposed me to a lot of ideas and stuff.
And I knew somehow I had to be in the mainstream, find my way to the mainstream or else I would not survive.
And so I recognized that. And I spent a lot of time in the library at a public library close by.
Unfortunately, my reading was on discipline. I like to read novels, history, historic novels and stuff.
But at some times some real hard discipline reading I would do. But for the most part it was not the kind of hard, noves reading that forms a brilliant mind.
But anyway, I had to read the helps.
What were schools like in Newark and then in East Orange? What were the schools like?
Were they integrated?
No, Newark was when I was in Newark, my entire 12 years old, that was where we were in poverty.
And the people from the South, the migration from the South, was from my sisters were at the age of poultry.
My mother was very worried that they would, the gods would ask them, that they would be in the park and hide it or go on.
And she wanted to desperately get out of there.
And when my sister named me married, this guy had this bar on grill, she was able to satisfy that because the gods would be on the street after my sisters who at that time were 16 and so.
And she was certain that they might be in pregnant and suffered for a word of love.
And of course, she showed a double-sided cause I had more freedom.
She was not worried about me and proglating anybody, but she should have been that concerned, she was not.
When did you become aware of race?
I think early on when I was in maybe the sixth grade or so, we had two girls in the class who were friends, white girl and the black girl.
And I remember this to this day, the white girl had bangs and she fell from her back.
The black girl had braids and she would go to her hairpipe where she tried to.
She was a very close friend and at one point, the black girl and she and the black girl and the orange one.
The white girl went to the teacher and complained and the teacher had no sympathy for her.
She told her you should stay with your own kind.
She told me how the prejudice affected itself.
But this was in the nook school and even though the teacher said that to this white girl, had no sympathy for her.
When I was in New York, they schooled and stayed back and allowed things to play out.
When I was in East Orange school, they were at birth to any black white intercourse.
They looked at it all and they interviewed.
And what that showed me is that the very faces of prejudice, I'm sure that my teachers in East Orange,
now I know, were as concerned about as maybe as prejudice as the teachers in East Orange were, proofs of it.
But they stood back and let things play out.
And so what that showed me is how white prejudice has very strong.
The East Orange people intervened and wanted segregation to be imposed.
They couldn't do it by law anymore, but they wanted it imposed.
All the people, the teachers in New York were not that they were concerned, I guess, but they didn't appear.
You had very different experience in your book at Barringer High School, where you went for two years, and then you went to East Orange High School in your third year of high school.
Did you talk about, I think, a good example that you write about, what happened around the swimming pool, how it was organized, how it changed, and what your role was in that.
I don't know, I don't remember what great I was in now, but at one point, what would happen in gym and gym classes was that we had gym babies.
We had gym maybe three or four times a week.
We would play basketball, and I would say some callous medicine basketball.
And then, part of the class, the white kids would go down to the pool and either swim or learn to swim.
The blacks would not allow us to use the pool except on all of a sudden, we can't.
When the sexes, all the black women or girls would use the pool after class, and then the pool was clean.
The other week, again, the black boys would use the pool, and then the pool was cleaned out.
There was a ruling from the Supreme Court of Literacy that all the facilities had to be secreted.
All the school facilities had to be open to all people.
For that knowledge, I decided I was going to use the pool.
I don't know how I learned that I must have read the newspaper.
What was the story made?
I read this to bed about it.
What made it so absurd was that I couldn't swim.
I would have to go to the pool every day that was gym class when the white boys went down.
Once I went to the white boys, I stayed out of the pool. Nobody was in the pool with me.
I couldn't swim or scared to death, even a few feet of water because I didn't know.
I was in the pool alone during the class. I couldn't get any of the other blocks of joining me.
After that semester, I was threatened by the teachers that were going to experiment and I refused to run.
They pleaded with me to not do this, to stay on the floor like the others.
But my feeling was that I was entitled to use that pool that I was my right to use it.
If I had been white, that time, even if I couldn't swim was not the issue.
They would be teaching me to swim. They were teaching white kids who couldn't swim.
That was the time they were taught them to swim.
It was a very stressful time for me.
The result was that instead of allowing everybody to use the pool and opening it, they closed it.
The blood was a bad feature for the school. Each time I had one of the best swimming teams in the city.
I was winning a lot of tournaments and stuff like that.
But it decided that instead of opening the pool, everybody that would close it.
That showed me the great cost to white of segregation. They paid a price for it.
You enrolled at Lincoln University when you were 16. How did you come to Lincoln University?
Well, I skipped a lot of classes. I was considered very bright.
I was a very good test doctor.
I was a good fitter by testing for anybody else in Lincoln class.
Now, I was considered brilliant.
I guess I can accept that.
But it seems to me that that's a gift too.
To learn to take tests.
That's not necessarily mean intellectual gifts.
But at the time, because I was so good, I was considered as a intellectual gifted.
I'll accept that.
What was Lincoln like at Lincoln University?
What was it like to be a student at Lincoln University?
The Lincoln University was a great experience of me.
I really had such a wonderful time there.
It was isolated and off the high-brewed path.
We spent a lot of time together to friends, my friends and I.
I was not interested at that time in the hard sciences.
What I was interested in was the social sciences.
While I was in the laboratory and so forth, I'd be looking out wanting to be on the campus playing ball.
It was really one of the very great times in my life.
I was so happy to have friends and people there because we were so isolated.
It was the first time you would have predominantly black educational environment.
Did that have something to do with it?
What I learned, however, was that it was not the school.
It was a time when I had all my friends and people there.
I went back some time later with the sport was going.
How did your time at Lincoln prepare you for civil rights activism, do you think?
When we were at Lincoln, we were an old male school.
And it's professors were former professors, retired from Princeton.
The head of the provost of one of the years of Lincoln was Princeton graduate.
They never, the Lincoln member at that time, very bored, we were good drunk and chair things down and so forth.
There was no effort to curb this and when we came along, we thought that this was being
preserved or listed, that the faculty was, that they sort of condoned this as a way that was had to be accepted
because black, black, when I'm unable to control them so.
So my generation of school felt that we ought to be able to control ourselves.
We didn't have to be breaking up things and stuff like that.
We were young men, supposed to be educated.
And so we should not tolerate this boring behavior that was being exhibited by an unacceptable.
We started agitating for black faculty, for more blacks, on the faculty.
There was only one professor, a English black on the faculty, all the rest of the people were white.
We began agitating for that.
I think, and we, was on the debating, was on the debating team.
And we had debates for the small colleges like Haverford and not the Ivy League schools and colleges were just below that.
And I think what that did for me was to enable me to not fear competing with white.
That gave me some courage and understanding that I could be, I was, compete with white people.
Which is one of the problems at that time that blacks, blacks have the whole head because they were stereotypes.
The worst about being able to compete with white people.
But that was a good time in my life that I learned.
That was helpful.
How did you come to choose to go to Howard University Law School University School of Law?
How did I come?
From Lincoln, you went to Howard University Law School.
I was, I went to Howard University Law School University School of Law on scholarship.
One of the people was recruited.
And I had never thought I could be a good lawyer because of my voice.
I don't have a good voice.
And I thought a good lawyer had to have a big voice.
And you know, it was a claim.
But I found that you didn't have to do that to be a decent lawyer.
What I had to do was to be able to know the fact and to be able to be conversant with all the facts and the law.
And my idol was William H. (William) Hastie who was a dean of Howard University Law School University School of Law.
He didn't have a good voice, but he was very, very smart and nullified.
And I came to realize that when I heard a law case that what I had to do was know all the facts, be conversant with all the facts.
So I could answer all the questions.
I didn't have to decline.
That was not helped me to become aware that I could be a good lawyer.
And tell what it was it liked to be a law student at Howard University Law School University.
You enrolled in 1937 in the fall.
Well, it was at the time how it was on a special mission.
The Charles Hamilton Houston had a program that we were going to fight segregation.
It was the separate-but-equal doctrine of Plessy v. Ferguson.
And we were going to fight it by making all the institutions, the state institutions, that offered courses for whites and not for black to offer duplicate courses for black.
All of us established separate schools for black.
And we knew that I couldn't do that.
And finally what happened was that as we thought to make them offer these separate courses,
we realized that they could not pay for it.
And so they began to graduate school.
They began to accept black without segregation.
All they would do as I did in my first case (heard) before Supreme Court.
the separate-but-equal doctrine, and this case, McLaurin, they tried to provide the separate-but-equal doctrine.
McLaurin was in the same class, in the same faculty.
All his segregation was that he was required to sit in a special seat.
He was required to sit in a separate table.
And he had maybe a rope around him.
But this was considered really separate political.
This was the beginning of the progress that's around.
Because she won that case.
That was my first case.
The Supreme Court held up the separation to provide him all the ability to earn his profession.
And that separate school does segregation itself to provide him all the ability to earn.
But let's go back to Howard University Law School just for a little bit.
Back to Howard University Law School when you were a student.
You mentioned Charles (Hamilton) Houston.
And while you were a student at Howard University Law School, he tried the first major case that would be part of the case leading to Brown.
The gains case.
And you were there to see that.
And also he came to Howard University Law School the day before from Moot Court.
Could you tell that story about Moot Court and then going to the Supreme Court and watching him try that case?
Well, my first time I wasn't a Supreme Court building.
I heard his argument before the Supreme Court and the gains case.
This guy, Missouri ex rel. Gaines, was seeking equal education opportunities.
And the head of school for gain.
And I heard the school and gains for poor blacks.
No school for prices I recall.
No school for.
I was wondering if you could unwind the student's outlook.
You ready?
Yeah.
Okay.
If you want to start by University of Missouri, the gains case at the Supreme Court.
was the first argument that I had this in with this in the United States Supreme Court.
And there were two things about the cases I recall that became a tradition.
The day before the argument we had an argument at the school, at the law school.
And and the course of the argument, Charles Hamilton Houston, argued the case.
One of the justices asked Mr. Houston a question that one of the students and the
priest's pre-year-end, or the argument before us, had queried at S.
and that made all the Supreme Court arguments brought by the NACP auspices and legal defense
fund.
We all those arguments were made to the Howard University Law School University School of Law before the day before the
argument by the Supreme Court.
And that became a tradition for a long time.
And that was, we got a lot of, I've run with that and heard, you know, people Houston
and all the dirt good that I, we always argue the excuses before the night before.
And that was not.
So how was Houston in the Supreme Court?
What was it like seeing Houston argue the gains case in the Supreme Court and being there?
Well, I got, I was always sort of nervous at first and then I got, we're getting involved
in the argument and I lose it, but I was, now but watching Houston argue the gains case,
what happens in that instance?
Houston argued the gains case and of course, of his argument when he was, when the case
was called, Justice (James Clark) McReynolds's turned his back on Houston throughout his argument.
The story goes is probably not, not true, that after the case was over, that Justice
(Justice James Clark) McReynolds had his best barber was doing his hair and he said that I just heard the nigga
of Houston argue the case in the Supreme Court.
And so the barber turned to him, Mr. Doc and said that Mr. Houston, we consider him
one of the great people and we think he is capable and qualified to sit on the Supreme
Court.
And if he did, we know that he would represent all the people and not just a few.
The story goes that I said, he told that that (Justice James Clark) McReynolds's, you know, he began to stop him
in his chair.
I don't know what that's true or not, but I hope it was.
That's a great story.
Any, just quick impressions of Charles Hamilton Houston?
Quick impressions of Houston that you had.
Any impressions of Charles Hamilton Houston as a person?
Anything stand out to you?
Any impressions of him?
Of Charles Hamilton Houston.
He was a formidable guy.
I did not very well.
And I only heard him argue a few cases because I wanted to case it because he, I think,
had money problem.
And yet he could not stay with the NAACP.
He had to return to that job, I was too afraid because he had to get a child or son
I think.
And he had to go on the backs of world and look for money.
So I was not, I was not, but Hasty was the, was the, my icon, I don't know if he was
a tool.
The other big event that happened during your years at Howard University Law School University School of Law was on Easter
Sunday in 1939 when you were among the group that had heard that.
And you had a job that day to do.
You were working in a restaurant and you made a decision.
Well, I had a scholarship to the law school, but I also had a part of time job.
First is a bus boy and then is a waiter to make some extra money.
And also to help me, to help my, to buy a school.
So I was tables.
The Marian Anderson concert.
I don't know, they refused to allow her, the daughter of the American Revolution, but
refused to allow her to sing at Constitution Hall.
So Mrs. Roosevelt arranged for her to sing at the Lincoln Memorial.
That day it was, I asked to be off, but I was refused of course.
And I hope that I was going to be a waiter for like, I knew that was my, so I just, I just
went to the concert.
It was a memorable.
It was really, you know, everybody was health and tears and I cried, it grew like
I probably used to it.
She sang beautifully.
It was historic.
And I went, when I got back to the, to the hotel, the dining room was in chaos.
And so, you know, I got straight now.
And after the, the evening meal was over, I was fired as I was expected to be.
There was resource that had fired me.
And I was not unprepared for that.
But what happened after I was fired was that I got a full scholarship to the, so working
the library, part, part time.
And so I worked in the library, did my lessons and stuff like that.
And it was, works, got money for that.
And so the whole thing was a boost for me.
Did you describe a little bit more that being in that crowd?
What was so moving about being at the Lincoln Memorial?
What did it look like?
Well, we all know that this was, this was being there.
She was in great voice.
And here this black woman was at the Lincoln Memorial singing.
I was de-segregated the, (Marian Anderson's 1939) desegregation of Constitution Hall by the DAR.
she had desegregated Constitution Hall.
And she had de-segregated, I mean, they wanted, she had desegregated Constitution Hall.
But after that they were out of the picture because that was why Mrs. Roosevelt got married
and it's the same at Lincoln Memorial.
And the crowd was integrated?
It was all.
Oh, good.
That was a big, big crowd as I recall.
Everybody was, was, was in tears, at least I was crying because we thought history was
being made.
This was, so, this woman was such great voice and the first black woman to sing before this
was a huge, large, integrated crowd.
The huge gathering.
It was a historic time.
Okay.
When you graduated from Howard University Law School, you went off to Columbia on a scholarship.
What were your plans leaving Howard University Law School University School of Law?
How did you see your future?
And why did you go to Columbia?
Well, I was, I had not really focused on I was, I have worked at the other one.
I had to, I thought that I had explored it to the limits and there was nothing else.
Well, let's back up because you didn't go to the NAACP until after the war.
You didn't go to the NAACP until after World War II.
You went to Columbia on the Rosenwald Fellowship fellowship?
Oh, I would.
Yeah.
I was on a, I was on a scholarship, working on a First Amendment issues.
And I hope was for my thesis that I was working on was to extend to watch the right to First
Amendment strike or essential for a democratic process.
It got me very excited about it.
And during that, at that time, when I was, my thesis, when I decided I was going to work
on this, I had two avenues.
I could work full time on that issue and take few classes and I would be able to get my
doctorate, because I was working on a doctorate to research.
I could get my doctorate after our years residents and I had five years to complete it.
I could complete part of my dissertation or I could take a whole lot of courses and
get my doctorate, my masters and all that way.
So more difficult was to write part of my thesis and I was advised by the faculty to
take the courses that the other way was more difficult.
And I had no idea.
And so I decided to, that I was going to work on my thesis and try to finish it and have
it accepted.
And I chose incorrectly my advisor.
I chose a Noel Dowling, whom's in my class and the law school, he had read the text.
He was one of these technicians who felt that the Supreme Court differences were based upon
this slight change and a little change in this, not on the social scene.
I was outside the court and I thought that was not sense.
But I also felt that I learned from him that in arguing before the court, that this
sometimes did you good to make these all the sections because the court would find a way
to rule for you without making an overwhelming rule.
And I learned although my feeling was that the Supreme Court changes followed the vote
and that political change was reflected in the Supreme Court's rulings.
And the process of getting out a case, a ruling with a case, it was good to be able to
argue these all the sections because it helped the court I realized make a ruling without
admitting that it was politically effective.
So I learned the law from you.
Okay.
Hold on and hold your next question because I need to put a new tape.
The next one, we're going to get to World War II and I'll just ask you how did World War
II impact your life?
And that's a good question, don't you think?
And start out by saying World War II because they're not going to have my questions in your
tape.
They're just going to have you talking.
So either repeat the question or just say World War II.
I think the point to emphasize, he's not taping right now.
Start with how you didn't resist the draft, you went in and describe how you entered the
Army Air Force and your involvement in World War II, its impact on you.
Just pick up where you were just now.
Yeah.
Yeah, pick up in the summer of 1941, you did not resist the draft.
Well, I was at the time I had thought that I had gone as far as I could go.
And fighting segregation, I thought there was nothing else to do that I had exhausted all
the avenues of fighting, fighting segregation.
I was restless and here I was also of some age.
And I didn't feel comfortable or that I had anywhere that my career, I was worried
about what I could do with my career.
And so I didn't resist the draft.
I thought that if I got anything on me, I would improve my health and all that's so
all I could say, which is it, I guess I'm out of luck.
And when World War II broke out, Pearl Harbor and so forth, I was in the Army.
And there came at a time when the NAACP was arguing and fighting for blacks to become a
part of the Army, not just as servants.
And up to that point, they had not had these black people, there were a few black units,
all black units, but they had had all these blacks to be interpreted into the Army.
They presented a problem to them because they hadn't had a core of black men trained for
anything.
And all the long time people who had been in the Army were people who were not well-educated,
people they had operated as servants to white men, to white officers.
And these men, like they were staff sergeants and so forth, but these were the only blacks
who had any standing and experience.
And so these blacks became the people that they utilized to take in and train and discipline
all these new blacks that were coming in.
The NAACP and other people were very concerned about that and their agitation for the
fall of the train black people to these black workers to give them opportunity to become
officers and so forth.
And it was in that setting that I became part of the Army.
Army Air Corps was called at the time.
We had no training, had this sergeant who was ignorant, who was a staff sergeant.
And what we did for the most part, what they had is doing for the most part, was clearing
bush.
We went to Augusta, GA and we were clearing trees and cutting down trees and clearing
them.
And I knew that I wasn't going to, that was for me.
So I wasn't a lawyer at the time.
I had a lot of legal education, but I had passed the board.
But that didn't, I mean, the staff sergeant who was now in charge of these blacks recruiting
and the job of Austin so forth was an ignorant, long time, Army men.
He had a couple of wives had all kinds of problems.
And so I became his lawyer.
I represented him and advised him about his domestic problem.
And as a result, I was given, I was not, I was not, I was not, I was not, I was not, I was
not, in that workforce, clearly, but I was in his office as his advisor on various aspects.
And then I had a problem.
How about that, Puppard Hayes?
Yeah, well, I think the detail is interesting, but really, so important is your experience,
how your experience in the Army sets you on the course of your life as a civil rights
lawyer.
And you know, the kind of racism you experience, you just said before, I've taken it, it was
devastating.
Well, what I knew at the time that I was not going to, for my time, cleaning brush and
that sort of stuff that I had to find a way out of that.
So I became this man's personal lawyer and represented him.
And after the agitation of the, you know, blocks for the opening of Army to, so for, for
the block, the recruits to be able to become officers and so forth, that agitation,
often a wave for a user get to off the campus school.
And I, he came a member of the quartermaster core.
And the Army was then, as I recall, segregated.
But we, as within the Army, that was segregated.
But within the Army, we had our exercises and so forth.
We worked in tents and as I recall, there may be 10 blocks and we were all in a tent
together.
But then we took classes and drills and stuff with, after-truement, our call for, for integration.
No?
No, that's 48.
You leave the Army at 44.
Okay.
Well, well, here's what you write.
I want you to react to this.
I was in the Army for a while.
He said it was the Army experience that made a militant of me.
I was in the Army.
And what bothered me the time about the Army was that, I was, I was, I was, I was, I was
in the Army.
So, segregation was, was so much a part of it that whites enlisted and had no respect
for black officers.
They wouldn't sell their losing so forth.
And I brought an action against several of them against them for not treating me with
respect.
That was one incident.
I think there were three incidents that occurred during that period of time that made the, the,
the base officer accused me of, of trying to riot, of crossing a riot, me alone.
And my theory was that at that point, now I'm not getting ahead of myself.
I was no longer enlisted when I'm talking about now.
I had become, I gone to the Officer Candidate School, I think.
And I had become an officer.
And I wasn't given any respect.
So at one point, and of course, I was on the base, they offered me the right to live off
the base.
I said I had no rights to live off the base, I was married.
And I had, I was going to, I had no intention that I was not on top of the group of the
base.
And of course, am I being on the, on the base one night, an officer came in the, in the
Howard.
And he was saying to me that this is one hell of a place.
And I said, he wanted to, I don't know, he wanted something for me.
And I was about to get to what the hell does he want.
And he was looking for, he was looking for, he was looking for the
He was looking for...
Hanger.
Not at a hanger.
Yeah.
He was looking for a hanger for his clothes.
And I was...
blind to give him.
And I said, that would.
And he said, this is one hell of a place.
Because he could find the hanger.
And I said, it certainly is.
And then...
And that said him all.
He stopped and started screaming.
Who is the snigger?
And...
when it was dark.
And he came up to me.
And I saw that he was a Lieutenant Colonel.
And he said to me, when he saw I was a...
and Officer was a Second Lieutenant + Lieutenant Colonel.
He said, I'm your superior by many grades.
And...
when...
you are supposed to be...
It's the right...
I'm your senior officer by many grades.
And you are supposed to...
acknowledge that as something like that.
And I said,
you may be my senior officer by many grades.
But once you're after, it was done.
And when you learn some manners,
I will...
I will be able to respect you.
But in the meantime,
got the hell out of my room.
Um...
And he was...
furious.
And the next day,
I saw him...
in the...
little train, you know, washing up.
And he had on...
he was head on his...
his shorts.
He was like an except boy shorts.
And I replied with his expose, body.
When he saw me, got rid of his...
out of the beach.
And...
he was...
he could have...
quite more shortly.
I was trying to.
But...
I think...
that he...
he was afraid he couldn't...
he couldn't run that battle.
Because...
he knew...
that he had been discontent.
And...
that was...
my...
my time in the army.
The thing I...
that was an incident that...
that really set me off.
And then...
um...
I...
laughed for five minutes.
I said...
I tried...
I brought for charges against a couple...
a couple of while I missed him in.
Uh...
because they didn't show me any respect.
And...
the officer...
the base commander...
was handing me the business that he was...
from Fajit, from...
from Mont.
And so forth.
But...
um...
you know...
things were...
were changing time.
And then I...
I couldn't...
revolutionize things...
right then and there.
And...
I told him I wasn't trying to revolutionize things.
But I thought...
that as an officer,
I was entitled to respect.
And I entitled to...
to get it.
Or...
I was going to go...
fighting Washington.
He wanted me to live off the base.
I didn't want to live off the base.
Um...
so...
I was then...
very soon transferred.
Um...
I...
I won time...
in the office club.
I told you I trusted that.
Tell the story.
Just told you.
No, you didn't tell the story.
I was in the office club.
And...
it was...
at a bar...
that was sort of the bar.
And...
white officers of course were there.
And I went up to the bar...
to ask to...
to put his drink.
The bar tender was a black man...
who was as looked as frightened as I felt.
Because I was...
I had the work of so like a born...
and...
I ordered a drink.
And he said he didn't know what he could serve.
And I said, well, why am I...
an officer?
Why can't you serve me?
You sound a little blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
And...
so...
he finally said the okay...
and...
poured me to the drink.
But then I quit and put in cash.
There were ships...
that I had to have.
And he couldn't accept the cash.
One of the...
the other white officers standing by...
was talking to put it on his bill.
I thanked him.
And I finished...
finished my drink.
And...
that audio...
was so devastating...
that I never...
never tried it again.
There was just too...
too much for him.
I...
I should have gone back...
but once was enough.
Ha ha ha ha.
So...
something that I was...
How did...
your experiences that you just told us about?
How did that affect how you felt
when you came out of the army
and what you did with your career?
How did the army change you?
How did it...
try you to the NAACP?
I had...
before I went into the army...
was...
I'd come over here...
and...
I had these friends and so forth.
And I almost...
was...
had the feeling...
that...
segregation...
and discrimination...
were not really issues...
because...
I had all these friends...
around...
and we were...
friendly together and did take together.
And...
that if you worked hard...
and so forth, that you could...
beat the system...
and so forth.
Unfortunately...
for my well-being...
I went into the army...
and...
the hatred...
against black soldiers...
was so vicious...
and virulent...
that...
it was good in all my eyes...
that I realized...
that...
segregation was a virulent thing...
and that...
you had to fight...
that was a good lesson for me...
because...
I really had...
almost come to the conclusion...
that...
discrimination...
if you worked hard and so forth...
you could...
live...
and...
in this country...
without discrimination bothering you.
And then I...
I became to understand...
as I went to the army...
that...
being...
uneducated...
there was a discrimination again...
being educated...
didn't save you from...
the viciousness of discrimination...
and that was a very, very...
good lesson for me...
and...
when I came out of the army...
out of the army...
I was determined to...
to fight segregation...
and to do what my life...
to that...
and that...
was...
I was made my motivation...
for...
for the rest of my life...
the amazing...
thing that was...
that now the army...
and the Air Force...
are institutions...
in this country...
that are...
more nearly...
acceptance of diversity...
and equal opportunity...
than any other institutions...
in the country...
and that's amazing thing...
how...
that institution has changed...
so...
the Air Force and the Army...
are now...
places where...
blocks...
are...
as...
as able to get equal opportunity...
as any institution...
and the United States...
as...
do you want to break?
Huh?
you want to keep going?
stop to you...
let's get you to the NAACP...
how are we doing back there?
as far as time...
we...
are we through?
no...
with recorded half of the situation...
we can go for another 30 minutes...
I must take it forward...
okay...
so we'll go as long as he's comfortable...
and then we'll break...
we'll get into the NAACP...
well, whenever you're tired...
you want to take a break...
let us know...
or hot...
but the next part is...
how you get to the NAACP...
you come out of the Army in 1944...
how...
you end up working in the NAACP...
and you come back with this commitment?
I...
I came out of the Army...
and...
I really was very...
a very country-ballton...
and I...
knew nothing about the NAACP tradition...
I didn't...
I hadn't heard of Thurgood Marshall Marshall...
I...
I hadn't heard of (William) Hastie...
was from East Orange...
and...
the NAACP...
and Roy Wilkins Wilkins and all those people...
I had never heard of them...
and this was...
when I came out of the Army...
I guess...
because...
I was...
I had gotten into trouble...
with...
any Army because...
I...
refused to accept segregation...
and I was fighting segregation...
and I was fighting...
talking about it.
On some of the...
the Army, I got in a bad...
bad with the Army...
official...
because...
they...
took me on as they thought I was...
took me on to be a snitch...
I was supposed...
I was supposed to...
report to the officers...
or the trouble makers...
and...
the thing that was so amusing...
was when they found out that...
I was not...
I was...
you know...
I had a...
a liberal newspaper delivered to me...
and stuff...
and that's how I wasn't...
going to...
one of those was going to be stitching on the other...
I was probably...
making trouble...
and complaining...
and stuff myself...
and...
the officers...
um...
began to...
call me...
a...
trouble...
okay...
um...
well we kind of did the Army...
stuff...
so...
you come out and you reconnect with William H. (William) Hastie...
wasn't that what happened?
you reconnected with William H. (William) Hastie when you came out of the Army?
what about coming?
but that's not so important...
we don't have to do that...
I mean you went to work for the NSP in 1944...
I've been working on it...
yeah...
well I came out of the...
when I was discharged from the Army in 1944...
William H. (William) Hastie...
was the dean of Howard University Law School University School of Law...
and...
he...
told her good...
it's a thought to recruit me...
so he thought I should...
I would be good on this day...
and...
I...
went on his...
I went on the staff...
and then...
I got drafted...
again...
and...
I had trouble with him...
I told him...
so I didn't go over this again...
and...
when I settled my problems with the Army...
I...
followed...
(William) Hastie's...
advice...
and so...
I didn't know I was now...
three of...
I had my...
my arm well discharged and I was free of all things...
I...
followed his advice...
and so...
the war wasn't over...
and so to rejoin the Army in some capacity...
um...
and...
I was...
turned down...
but as a general...
well thanks for...
thanks for nothing...
and...
I think I...
I wasn't a good soldier...
I think I could...
could have been a better one...
if I had...
I've been allowed to...
be sort of...
have some...
freedom of action...
and I had the face all this...
the snancet...
but...
it was an experience...
that...
affected my life...
and...
I got out...
and I was...
and I was going to spend my life on the school...
So what better place in the NAACP?
Mm-hmm...
So what happened?
You're hired and what...
what were you hired to do?
What?
What were you hired to do at the NAACP?
I was hired to...
at the time when...
when the NAACP...
at Howard University Law School University...
was on a special program.
And...
that program...
we were designing...
cases...
to desegregate state institutions.
And...
the issue was...
for the trying to casrate...
of block lawyers...
that would go...
into institutions back to their hometown...
and...
find...
just...
and fight discrimination...
bring cases and so forth.
On the screen...
and...
that was the...
the program that...
that...
Howard University Law School University...
carried on for some time.
So...
the...
at first...
the whole purpose of the program...
was to find state institutions...
that...
and the separate-but-equal doctrine...
and the Puzzlers' Ferguson...
that offered...
gains...
goods...
or services...
or education...
for whites...
and not for blacks.
And...
these lawyers...
on the Houston's program...
were to bring litigation...
to forced...
whites...
institutions...
to either...
set up...
program...
and accept blocks...
or...
be faced for litigation.
And...
I continued for quite a while.
What was your relationship with Thurgood Marshall Marshall Marshall?
Because at this time he was heading it up...
Houston had gone back to Washington.
Well...
I'm my first...
I'm one of the first...
of Thurgood Marshall Marshall.
1944.
My first...
contact with Thurgood Marshall Marshall...
was...
I was on his staff...
and...
I was sort of...
given a...
because I had all this...
education...
I was given a...
a little...
couple of holes in myself...
and...
well I was supposed to be I guess.
Um...
the message grew.
And I...
uh...
the rest of us were...
of a staff was in a big room...
and I had this little...
look...
couple of holes to myself.
And...
at one point...
Thurgood Marshall Marshall, we had to...
get a briefing...
um...
the staff...
uh...
we were on a case...
the separate-but-equal doctrine...
and gains...
I think I wasn't good.
We were on a case...
um...
now yeah.
Okay, it was 1938.
I had to...
write...
I was writing a...
uh...
was to write a brief.
No.
We had to get this briefing.
Um...
now what was...
what's the case with that?
Um...
Thurgood Marshall Marshall...
was...
Thurgood Marshall Marshall was...
was Thurgood Marshall Marshall without a lunch.
Uh-huh.
And I was given...
I was told by his secretary...
to do the briefing.
I was...
I was very reluctant to do it
because I thought that...
I should have been authorized.
And...
they had long lunches
and so...
and when he got back...
the brief was done.
And he walked over it
and sent it out.
And put that on...
from that time on...
I began to...
be the...
dry who was doing the briefs
and things like that.
Um...
behind the scenes.
Uh...
I did that for...
a long time.
And I...
did not...
have my name...
or honor.
And it's like that it didn't matter to me.
But after a while I began to feel
that I should get some credit for it.
So you would...
Right.
In addition to that...
so you're really running the litigation program,
writing the briefs.
But you also traveled a lot
as an NAACP lawyer.
You visited every...
you tried cases in every state in the South.
And you have a description of what that was like.
Um...
Can you talk about your travels in the South
and going into these courtrooms
where black people would come in to watch?
Um...
Well...
when we had...
cases...
as our time...
there were public servants.
And...
the first case...
like teacher Sauer case.
Concent...
Maltley.
And I tried to try that case.
This was the first time
that I'd seen a black woman lawyer.
And Mississippi.
And...
the people were...
ecstatic because we were playing the...
superintendent on the hot seat.
And they were...
reenacting our courtroom...
courtroom drama as we...
actually...
we explored where these people on the cross-examination
put them on the hot seat and everything like that.
And they would reenact all this stuff
in the court and the barbershops and stuff...
um...
Concent's...
Maltley was the first woman, black woman lawyer
I'd...
and Mississippi.
So I'll argue a case.
And...
now of course...
I'm sure that black women are commonplace
arguing cases in Mississippi never place out.
So...
but this was the first...
she was the first black woman they had seen.
And...
that was just amazing.
So you know this...
this black woman was...
was her...
her...
this case.
And...
now she's that's commonplace.
We're doing back there.
So people would crowd into the courtrooms...
African Americans would pack the courtrooms
when you would go into try a case.
Well, that was during that period of time they would.
In the federal court...
there was no segregation.
I wouldn't allow her to go.
Stayed court.
There was.
But the blacks were so crowded and whites...
white people wanted to get in.
But they couldn't compete with all these black...
black folks in South Lake.
For most people out there were...
I wouldn't know who that's...
who that's listening.
But in the federal court...
there's no allow of that.
That's segregation.
And so blacks filled out the courtrooms.
And...
those these things were enacted.
And Constance Baker Motley would...
tell the...
would be asked asking...
trouble...
or I would be asking questions.
And at some point...
the white superintendant...
would want to ask me a question...
or a kind of question.
And the audience would laugh or say no...
I...
I make the...
I ask you the question...
do you respond?
You...
it's not your...
your role that...
to ask me...
you respond to questions I put.
And...
you know, the audience...
it was precarious.
The audience...
was so...
bowed down with...
with segregation and discrimination.
I bet precarious, like...
lived through us...
or through us...
this...
this joy of being able...
to...
put the questions...
and put...
white superintendents...
who...
forced segregation...
on the hot seat.
And then you'd hear a word that they'd re-enact that scene.
You say that again...
you would hear that they...
what?
You heard word that they would...
that the people in the community...
would re-enact.
They...
they would re-enact the stuff in that barber shops...
and...
beauty parlors...
all over town.
That was a...
a very interesting era.
But...
I... you know, after a while...
it...
it was no longer...
the theater that used to be.
I moved outside.
I think we have a few minutes on this tape.
What was it like traveling in the segregated south...
as a young lawyer?
Well...
I would...
I didn't have too much difficulty.
But...
what I...
what you did when you traveled...
for...
for most part...
you had no...
hotel facilities.
After a while you did had decent facilities...
but...
as I recall...
when I argued that the figure...
case...
one of the...
the first of the browns...
states...
cases...
Jack Greenberg...
and I...
had to stay in a hotel.
And this was an awful hotel...
I thought...
Tom Jacques...
we didn't have to stay there...
what he should do was stay at a decent hotel.
He refused, of course.
But...
subsequently...
we began to find some decent accommodation.
But...
at first...
it was just awful...
to find some...
some decent place...
to...
to stay an eventually...
an eventually...
at a time...
we stayed with...
with black friends.
We almost had to have our point.
We had...
15 minutes...
to make our stay a little bit further...
you're ready to take a rest.
How much further we have to go?
We didn't even get to brown yet.
Okay, well let's try one more question...
we'll see how it does.
How about...
your first case before the Supreme Court was in McLaurin v. Oklahoma State Regents...
in that earlier?
Can you describe that case...
and what that experience was like going before then?
It was...
as I remember McLaurin v. Oklahoma State Regents.
Well...
Actually, you described that...
McLaurin was...
this was called real separate...
separate but equal.
McLaurin had...
they couldn't say he didn't have the same facility.
He had the...
he had the same facility.
He was required to sit in a special seat.
And...
and he was...
wrote off from his classmates...
and a special...
special...
lunch place...
and so forth.
But...
the same books, the same professors.
We argued that...
he was denied equal...
as you can't stop the presidency...
because he was segregated...
he was not permitted to have intellectual intercourse...
with his fellow students.
We really...
had a problem...
with some of our...
public about that...
because many of the...
some of the people...
thought that we were carrying...
to fall that we were...
certain to lose...
because...
the separate but equal doctrine...
was...
was being played out before us.
And I felt that the...
differences were too insubstantial...
for us to win the case.
And...
third was...
very...
politically...
a stoop.
He...
he brought these cases...
and made public...
statements and so forth...
about them.
And...
did so...
to not allow...
the people...
supporting segregation...
to have the day.
And...
although...
each time...
he proves...
correct...
the Supreme Court...
in our favor...
the next time...
you know, the next case...
they said...
we're going to fall...
because...
the Supreme Court is...
too insubstantial and so forth.
But he was...
he was a good publicist...
for you know...
how to...
how to handle the case.
It's like that.
And...
there was really...
a...
very great time for me.
Okay.
All right.
See how much further we can get here.
In June of 1950...
you talked about...
equalization trying to push...
Plessy v. Ferguson with its limit.
But in June of 1950...
the lawyers decided to attack
Plessy v. Ferguson directly.
Okay.
You talk about that shift in strategy...
and the significance of it?
Well...
it was really...
a sort of a half...
shift...
because...
we...
told our people...
that we were...
going to...
take only cases...
that...
that we were going to attack
segregation percent...
as being...
unconstitutional.
And that we're not going to...
concentrate...
on...
unequal facilities.
Although...
we did...
as a backup.
You know...
it...
showed unequal facilities.
But our...
our main thrust...
was...
that segregation percent...
was unconstitutional.
Because our theory was...
that...
the state could equalize...
or try to...
equalize the facilities.
And our clothes were dapped.
And...
we might...
win.
So we had to...
argue...
that segregation was unconstitutional.
At the same time...
we also...
argued...
that I'm not...
about unequal facilities.
So we were...
we didn't really give up...
the unequal facilities...
argued that was a fallback on plan.
But here's where your role is so important...
about...
what were you going to use...
bring in social science and Kenneth Clark?
Can you talk about your role...
in this development of strategies...
for challenging plusy?
For challenging plusy?
For challenging segregation in the schools.
How are you going to make the case?
That separate could not be equal.
Well...
what I was...
the first...
step...
was...
Charles Hamilton Houston...
thesis, I have to...
what's the point of all these cases...
and...
make them so expensive.
For...
for...
the states to maintain.
And the theory was that they would...
then...
have to allow...
blocks in the white institutions.
And...
if they did that...
after graduate...
and college...
level...
then...
it would be clear...
that nothing...
ends with what happened.
It would be clear...
that...
segregation...
was...
could be maintained peaceful...
and that wouldn't be right...
and all that sort of stuff.
So...
that was what...
we first began...
doing.
And then when we came to...
that was at the...
the high school and so forth level.
When it came to...
the...
great schools...
we didn't have the luxury...
of...
faculty...
of the...
of the rely on.
We didn't have the luxury...
of the exclusiveness...
of...
of alumni.
We didn't have all those...
those things we had in...
and the graduate schools...
and in Sweatt v. Painter...
and so forth.
All the schools...
were presumably...
one like thousand.
Maybe...
they may have been some specialized...
grammar schools...
but for the most part...
they were supposed to be...
all the same.
And...
this was...
Brown...
when Brown...
was the board...
came...
was...
this came up when we...
we had to...
argue...
that segregation per se...
was unconstitutional...
that...
impaired the ability...
of white...
of black children to learn...
and...
we began...
that...
I'm wearing a suit...
holding the...
it sounds...
it sounds like a same view.
All right.
Okay.
So, I picked up with that.
Well...
we were preparing a case...
and clowns on county...
to segregate the schools.
And...
I thought Kleinberg...
was the...
chief social scientist...
at Columbia University...
at the social science department...
at Columbia University.
I made a study...
which showed...
that black migration...
on the segregated schools in the south...
to Philadelphia...
and...
that black migration...
on the segregated schools in the south...
to Philadelphia.
Then...
integrated...
that the longer they stayed...
in the Philadelphia system...
of segregation...
the higher...
the scores...
on...
tests...
of...
on all...
matters...
that...
measures...
their education ability.
Um...
we were...
then about to...
bring a case...
the case...
seeking...
to...
attack...
segregation...
and the county...
south Carolina schools.
And...
I went to...
Klineberg
and told him what we were doing.
And...
said that his study...
was exactly the thing we needed.
Uh...
he...
I was a black man...
and him, of course,
was initially a...
a library of getting involved...
because he didn't know where I was coming from.
But what he did say to me...
no, I'm...
I'm not going to help.
But he referred me to Kenneth + Mamie (Phipps) Clark.
Um...
I went to...
I had...
heard of them or their work.
And I went to...
um...
to them...
and told Kenneth what we were doing.
And...
I...
I asked him...
if he could help us.
And at that time...
they had...
man northside center...
for child development.
The only institution of his time...
of his kind and heart...
was...
sought to...
test the...
segregation impact...
on black children.
And...
he...
Kenneth...
and Amy had...
devised a stall test.
And the stall test...
was very, very...
uh...
provocative, I guess it was.
They would show...
a stall...
black doll and a white doll...
to children.
The good doll, bad doll.
The bad doll was always black.
The good doll was always black.
But the confusion was...
that the white doll was always...
them...
the child who was...
being interviewed.
And...
so...
the theory was...
that they thought of that...
was the impact of segregation...
and discrimination...
on black children...
because...
that...
it impaired their ability...
to learn.
And...
gave them a sense of inferiority.
Um...
I believe...
that...
the Clarendon County case...
was the...
was the only case...
that we use this test...
in...
in presentation.
Um...
we...
went to South Carolina...
and...
went to the Howard...
where we could work...
and get prepared for...
for the trial.
Um...
and one of the incidents that was...
very funny...
was that...
when the train...
got left the soft...
at the Charleston...
South Carolina...
County was running around...
trying to wear my dolls...
wearing my dolls...
and...
Spottswood Robinson...
who was...
one of our people had not been...
a prize of...
of what we were trying to do.
And he was...
he was looking at me...
on this...
and he thought...
he thought...
kind of was...
was kind of...
I'm wondering if you...
you got himself together when...
we told him what it was all about.
But...
I think that was the only case...
that we actually...
use the doll tested stuff...
who...
tested the children...
and...
had them testifying.
Uh...
all the times...
all the instances...
we had...
sociologists talk about it...
and on the wooden stage...
uh...
what happened when...
Kenneth joined forces with us on the cane...
uh...
in fact, almost a member of the stair...
was uh...
he...
was able to get...
professional witnesses for us...
to testifying various cases...
and so we didn't have to rely on...
of...
one or two people to become professional witnesses...
we had...
at a whole...
gravity of people we call the...
on to testifying us as experts for us...
and...
one of the things that...
I insisted on...
for these people...
was...
not to try to help us...
by testifying...
our other expertise...
stay within it...
don't try to help us by...
testifying...
the things that they couldn't support...
and when the...
academics...
were...
allowing that...
we began to...
that we'd done to relax...
and we saw like in a classroom...
they...
realized that they only had to...
testify...
about what they could support...
and back up...
and thus...
they relax and...
with their good witnesses...
because I said to them...
you know when you go outside your field...
you...
are not doing us anything good...
because...
what...
all the lawyers try to do...
is...
for the period of time...
of the cross-examination of several other cases...
and so long as much...
about...
your expertise...
and your views...
and how to...
how to...
cross-examine you...
as...
for that moment...
as an expert...
we try to become an expert...
like you...
and so...
you don't do us any good...
if...
you're an area of expertise...
because if you...
if you do, you're not helping us at all.
And...
when the academics...
learned that was what they wanted them to do...
they relaxed...
testified in their field...
and...
didn't...
you know...
get beyond that...
and so...
we were able to...
all people were able to...
to stay...
well within...
the area of expertise...
and what happened...
several times...
was that...
experts...
on the other side...
sought to...
testify...
outside their level of expertise...
and with...
Kenneth's help...
you know, he was at the...
a drug scene...
me...
at the...
post-evaluation...
we were able to make them pay for it.
That's good.
Could you say a little bit about...
how innovative...
the use of social science was...
in the brown...
case...
and how it was to the decision...
Yeah.
Well...
when we came...
to...
try to use the social science...
data...
in brown...
and we got...
the social scientist...
to follow a brief...
showing...
that segregation was harmful.
Some of the...
the...
people...
who...
on our committee...
were very dubious...
because it was not hard science.
And...
what...
they're good...
allowed me...
always to do...
as he allowed...
musical...
as far as I could...
as long as I could support it.
And so some of these...
some of our...
our...
advisors...
did go for the social science stuff...
because they said...
it wasn't hard science...
and they didn't believe in it.
And...
I told...
said to them...
well, I had nothing else.
I'm going to offer...
a...
then alternative...
fine...
but if not...
I'm going to take this risk...
and that's how...
social science...
worked out...
into it.
And...
um...
William T. Coleman Jr...
who...
was one of those who wrote that...
the social science was...
was...
not hard science...
came to agree...
that...
it was...
it was excellent.
It was the key.
Kenneth...
It was the key to Brown...
social science.
Yeah.
It was the key to Brown case.
But...
it was the case in Topeka, Kansas...
that we...
assessmentally came out.
The three...
uh...
cases...
and...
the...
cases...
that...
we were all going to segregation per side.
And...
could you...
state me what Brown...
the opinion, the majority opinion in Brown...
what it said, how it ruled...
in overturning segregation in the schools.
Brown hell...
that...
we argued, I should say,
equal education opportunity...
was...
uh...
having a...
a...
I've never been argued...
in an education case...
that...
it had been assumed...
by...
you know...
by a lot of lawyers and judges...
that...
equal...
education opportunity...
had been...
argued...
and...
the Supreme Court.
But...
what we were able to show...
what...
was that...
the Court had never...
looked at...
rather initially...
it had assumed...
that...
other courts...
had initially looked at...
at the issue...
of initial...
and so we argued...
that what the Court ought to do now...
is...
to look at...
the separate but equal doctrine...
and plus evoses Ferguson...
as...
being...
us never being...
uh...
argued...
in a...
segregate...
in a equal...
in an education case...
and...
looking at it for the first time...
find...
that...
separate but equal was on Constitution.
And that...
is...
a...
that...
was...
uh...
chief justice...
one...
bought that argument...
and...
wrote...
the opinion...
that...
we had indicated...
and that was the Brown Jones.
Okay...
And it really is based on the social science...
they grounded their opinion.
Yeah...
This was the first use of...
social science...
and we had a social science...
people...
writing a brief...
and support of the issue...
that segregation percent...
was on Constitution.
So...
what was your expectation...
when the court ruled unanimously...
in Brown?
Well...
what would happen?
I...
came to a court too with an conclusion...
that...
the court...
argued that the court...
reached unanimously...
and Brown won...
on the thesis...
that...
it would have to...
it would be unanimous...
but the implementation...
would be, as I said,
with all the...
speech, whatever that meant.
And...
the implementation...
meant that...
segregation...
was...
like in Topeka, Kansas...
the first case...
that...
the Topeka, Kansas...
did not school...
and...
did not...
do not...
do not school...
did not want...
that in one argument occurs...
that I wanted...
to...
to get out of it.
They...
were ready to concede...
and...
the Supreme Court...
I wanted the Supreme Court...
to hold...
in...
Topeka, Kansas...
that...
segregation...
was unconstitutional...
but...
since...
they...
decided that...
they weren't going to...
mute that test...
the court said it was mute...
and then reached the issue.
And...
I proved correct because...
when...
the All Deliberate Speed came out...
it took some...
ten or twenty years...
before...
Topeka, Kansas...
again reached the point...
that it was...
willing...
already for this segregation...
when...
the All Deliberate Speed...
is okay...
then...
the Topeka, Kansas...
case continued...
and...
the...
woman...
or the kid...
or the child...
who had brought the case...
initially...
and...
the city...
or the state did not want to...
once...
all the mute and the Supreme Court did...
and once I'm twenty years later...
there was still...
fighting...
of that case...
until...
I think...
they held...
more recently...
or tried to hold more...
that...
the time for...
all (All) Deliberate Speed did run out.
And...
throughout the South...
you had massive resistance...
in response to Brown.
And you really didn't have meaningful...
school deserigation anywhere in the South...
until after...
1968...
really, the...
1970-71.
So, how do you...
what is the significance of Brown?
Is it just about schools?
How do you see the significance of the Brown decision?
On what?
The significance of the Brown decision.
Well, the significance...
of Brown...
was...
it's holding...
that...
segregation...
was unconstitutional.
And...
it...
had significance...
because...
after a long period of time...
when it had...
sort of...
run out in the whole...
(All) Deliberate Speed business was going...
that...
we had to hold that...
segregation...
itself was illegal.
And...
the...
state...
finally...
came to that...
that path.
But the problem...
was that if it had...
held that...
without all the...
all the Liberate Speed...
indication...
we would have been long...
long gone.
They're all the Liberate Speed...
business...
delayed...
because nobody knew what all the Liberate Speed meant.
Or what it meant...
apparently was...
that you could just...
delay...
the implementation of Brown...
of the decision.
Um...
and...
the...
significance...
to...
me and Brown...
was...
that...
segregation...
was...
per se...
on Constitution...
that enforced...
segregation by law...
is...
no longer...
viable in this country.
And all that we still have segregation...
it is...
segregation...
that...
people are accepting...
but that it is not an issue...
but that it is not an enforced by law.
Um...
and...
I...
I think...
that at some point...
as the time is going to come...
when...
that's going to be this public...
at least I hope so...
this...
public forum...
to...
and...
the...
sort of volunteer segregation...
which...
the country is engaged in the present time.
We don't have...
we don't have segregation by...
by uh...
law anymore...
but...
people are still segregated...
and we don't have a...
a public urge...
to...
end it.
So...
that...
that is going to...
the beauty of the present...
is that...
at some point...
that is going to be this...
public push...
to...
and segregation...
and since that's no law,
they enforce it...
that...
with the voluntary segregation...
I'm hoping...
that is going to reach the point for it,
but not...
it will not be viable.
Okay.
Um...
A few more points to cover
with the important role you play
beyond Brown,
in addition to working for enforcement,
is that in the South,
the backlash to Brown,
trying to shut down the NAACP,
trying to outlaw the NAACP,
um...
you were able to draw on the work you did in Columbia
to fight that,
and you want to talk to me about that?
Well, first amendment...
The problem...
was that...
that when Brown was decided...
there was a backlash
against the NAACP,
we had...
not been bothered...
because...
the southerners didn't feel we were...
we were worth the bother with, you know...
NAACP.
But...
when the Brown case
was decided...
there went after us...
on the thesis
that if they...
could outlaw the association,
that...
that were in the problem for them.
Um...
So...
I heard that I spent a lot of time
fighting to...
keep the NAACP...
and...
a lot of time,
because we're being attacked
in various states
that try to outlaw us, try to...
do this and that
called some constitutional
and so forth and so on.
So...
I heard a...
a grueling spree...
protecting
and fighting
for the NAACP life.
Um...
because...
southerners felt
that if they...
outlawed the association...
that were in the problem,
they didn't realize...
that...
the association...
was not...
was not the...
the issue that...
the people
were concerned with it
and the...
and outlawing the association
that have to...
outlaw
other folks
who...
under some other name
would be fighting
that in segregation.
Universe...
NAACP v. Alabama
uh...
cases in the Supreme Court
was...
sought to...
um...
hall that...
the NAACP um...
was...
uh...
but hall were in the NAACP
right...
to...
fight segregation
as big...
unconstitutional.
And we had to...
bring cases
to show that we had to
right to seek
the educational
opportunities.
Uh...
free of
state coercion
and that was...
uh...
anyone?
Yeah, we're on that case.
And that was important
for all civil rights organizations.
That was important for the rights of all civil rights organizations
to fund me.
That was a very important case.
And then NAACP v. Button?
And an NAACP v. Button?
Another very
important case
which uh...
sought to
hold at the...
the NAACP uh...
outlawed the NAACP.
And...
we were able...
the court held
that we had a right to...
go on together
and the association
to peacefully
seek
uh...
educational (educational) opportunity
as easy.
Free that I was our first to
number right.
Okay.
We'll file a major point
that I think is important.
Is your decision?
You become General Counsel of the NAACP in 1955.
And you make a decision to turn attention to the North
and to the problem of
school segregation in the North.
Could you say a bit about
what...
why you did that and how you attempted to
apply brown beyond the South?
Well...
I...
Let me see how I can
so how I can...
turn this...
to this...
I had a...
I had a problem
with....
Jack Greenberg
And I had a problem.
Jack on Thurgood Marshall Marshall left.
Jack wanted to take Thurgood Marshall Marshall's place
and be the headman and reduced me to the role of no counsel.
While he ran the West West Stuckerts
and the West West Stuckerts
was sick all the Thurgood Marshall Marshall's role.
And my role was to just be a counsel for the NAACP
with no right to bring segregation cases.
And so forth.
And he tried to get Roy Wilkins to bar me
from bringing segregation cases
that they all should come to him
as a had a illegal defense plan.
And we heard a very, very fight public fight about that.
He sought to get Roy Wilkins to turn him into a fight
and he turned over to him all the segregation cases.
I was very bitter with him because
in the beginning I had been so helpful
on with me on segregation cases.
And then when Thurgood Marshall Marshall left
to go on the court, on the Second Circuit Court of Appeals Court of Appeals,
he thought that as counsel
a Thurgood Marshall Marshall's successor
that he could have Roy Wilkins bar me
from bringing it into segregation cases.
And they were all responsible for him.
The problem with that was that I had all the
segregation cases I had in my hands.
And I was certainly not going to turn over to him.
He thought he could get Roy Wilkins to do that,
to force me to that.
And Roy Wilkins was very bitter.
And he probably Roy Wilkins was not willing to have a public fight.
And he knew that if he tried to accept
Jack's plan, that that would be hell to pay.
And that's how Jack Greenberg and I had our problem
with one another, which now I don't know.
Now I have the association
because they fired Lewis M. Steel
and I was the mother of my staff
without notice to me
without consulting me
because he had written an article.
The article came out unfortunately
on a day that an ACP board was meeting
and a solder was nine men
and black, then quite.
I was told that Thurgood Marshall Marshall was on the court
at the time and he was furious.
And as a result of that article,
they fired Lewis M. Steel.
And I threatened
and my whole staff felt resigned
if they didn't reinstate him.
Fortunately Roy Wilkins was in Paris
and was unable to purchase stuff.
So it all came out.
And the I [Carter] was resigning.
And I got a hero.
Here I'm a black man with a pretty good job.
I was resigning my job
because they fired a part of it.
The officers of the serial town.
And so I,
at that point, I was sort of tired.
I didn't know where I was going
with school segregation
because I thought I had exhausted all the avenues.
But when I threatened to resign
if they didn't reinstate Lewis,
I began to get revitalization
because I thought for the wrong reason
because here I'm black
and I'm a resigning
a pretty good job
because a white man has been mistreated.
So,
I gave me a new lease on life.
I print it probably
helped me get a judgeship to I think.
Because I don't know how I was first
come up to be a judge
when Thurgood Marshall
and the Kennedy era,
Thurgood Marshall was one of two judges.
And they were ready to give him one
but only at the district level.
And he wanted something bigger than that.
And the Kennedy didn't at that time
feel that blacks were,
this was too good job for black,
a black man.
So they came after me.
And I had these people
that were want to mitigate a judgeship.
And Adam Adam Clayton Powell Jr Jr.
And I had a sort of a conversation.
And he indicated to me
that I had to pay
if I paid a certain amount of money
for the judgeship I could get.
So I told my advisors this.
And all hell broke loose
because they felt
that was a big to do
and so far so I ended up
with the people
have to back down
because of the politics of the issue.
And I always say that I was responsible
for, from Thurgood Marshall to Thurgood Marshall,
getting his corn of appeals appointment
because all the hell
about that was caused
by my people
that Powell had asked me
for money for any kind of
a dollar of money.
And in the end,
there was politics.
He had the votes.
So I was abandoned.
And I ended up with Thurgood Marshall getting it.
And I thought at that point
that my chance of getting a judgeship
had ended.
Several years later,
it kind of came to pass.
Before I finish up,
I just want to go back one more time
on the school piece.
Because when you left in 1968,
when you left the NAACP,
you were involved in the Ocean Hill-Brownsville case
in the Intermediate School 201 case.
And I think your fight for quality education
for black children
was beyond brown.
And I think that you were involved in the North
and deal with the problems
with segregated and unequal schools in the North.
So maybe if we want to reflect on that
on the state of education today,
what's happened,
what hasn't happened.
But your efforts in the North
were really pioneering.
In the North.
The issue of segregation
was not North South,
it was Nationwide.
The North and schools
didn't want to keep the schools segregated.
They were grueling,
grueling, and some of those.
But the North and school segregation
was not the issue of segregation.
It was the issue of keeping blocks
and white separate.
It was a national phenomenon.
There has been no push
recently to move.
And I expect that at some point
there was going to be an issue
of this manly voluntary school segregation.
I don't know.
But right now,
everybody is doing anything publicly.
The issue is grueling.
But I'm hoping at some point
there's going to be a push
for someone to
and voluntary segregation
to make it more a public issue again.
But so far, nothing.
I think the last question
we'll do our filling in.
In the light of your history
and your long struggle
in the civil rights movement,
how do you see the significance of Obama's election
related to your history
and to the struggles you've been involved in?
Well,
there have been several things
that happened with Obama
that were unexpected.
The passage of the
one of the bills
for equal education.
One of the bills
that Obama managed to get through
came as a shock and surprise.
But just the actual election of Obama.
We were all here that night.
Just his election.
How did that make you feel
in terms of your work
to break down barriers
to get voting rights in the South?
Any thoughts on that?
Just that moment?
Well,
I think that his election
was certainly supportive
of what I had hoped to achieve.
But my story
was not that I was not
a black president.
I wanted to still achieve
equal educational opportunities.
In fact,
for all, for the poor,
for blacks,
and so that everybody had
a chance of equal educational opportunities.
Because I think
that that's the key
to finding black equality
and diversity
to, for me,
Obama, is that everybody
was able to secure
equal education opportunities
that it would be so.
Now,
that may be an elitist view.
I don't know.
But that's how I look upon it.
And I am now
too old to pursue it
because I'm not one of those people
who tried not to be
who wants to stay on the stage
long after I've been useful.
I think that I've had my time
and younger people
ought to come after me.
And there are a number
of them who I think
are going to take
or take it over.
So,
I don't have any sense
to find
or to keep these for them
to come out
because
I have,
I'm sort of mentally
fatigued
and sometimes
I have
I do some little writing
and stuff like that.
But I really haven't done
anything of any substance
for a period of time.
I'm going to get simulated
to do something
but I don't know.
My feeling is maybe.
I've done this since then.
But I think
I have
I have a shape
of vegetation
and sometimes I
get weary of it.
But I
I'm not
wanting to go back.
If I get simulated
maybe I'll do some writing
and stuff.
But I don't know.
Okay.
Let's take a break and see
what the floor has for us to fill in.
So, can we start from here?
All right.
Speed, camera's rolling.
Ready?
Yes.
My cord, George W. McLaurin.
I think his name was George.
George W. McLaurin.
Start again.
Start from the beginning.
George.
George W. McLaurin.
I applied to the University of Oklahoma
graduate school.
And I was
given what?
Many of our
the public felt
that the public was the epitome
of the separate
because he was
taught by the same faculty
in the same class
all he had was a separate
seat in the lunch room
and the classroom.
And that was thought to be
the first time a
classroom.
How successful it
proved.
Long.
Great.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National
Museum of African American
History and Culture.